(thoughtful music)
If you hate your Monday through Friday
you're in big trouble.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- You're in big fucking trouble.
I fucking hate Friday, I really do.
I'm blown away by people
celebrating the end of the week.
It breaks my heart, my friends
like live for Friday night.
- Yeah.
- They know they got
the week, like Monday morning's the worst.
Like at its basic form, if
you genuinely celebrate Friday
you need to rethink your
entire fucking game.
To live your life where
you love Friday night,
Saturday and Sunday and
despise Monday through Thursday
or Friday morning is devastating to me
because you're wasting
too much of your life.
And I'm trying to put
pressure on the conversation
to say if you love Friday that much
then you need to really look
at Monday through Thursday.
If you literally start your week being sad
and it gets progressively
better, you have a problem.
We spend way too much time
in our lives doing our jobs.
When you're spending more
than half your life working
it's important that
that thing is on point.
It's just a math game.
If you're spending 83% of
your time, 72% of your time,
64% of your time on something
you hate, that's devastating.
How do people not understand
that when you eliminate
sleeping, it is what you do.
You basically live to work.
- Mm-hmm.
- If you're unhappy, where are you going?
If you were like running to Friday night,
that means you're miserable
Monday through Friday
and I lived that life.
I use to run to Friday
when I was in school,
and I hated Sunday night
with my entire heart.
I lived for snow days for like a decade.
(laughing)
Like for a decade the only
thing I gave a fuck about
was please can a Nor'easter come through
and eliminate school.
(laughing)
The thought that that is so
many peoples' work lives,
which will be the disproportion percentage
of how they live their
lives, breaks my heart.
It breaks my heart.
I'm not making this video
to cheer how lucky I am
or how cool it is that
I love what I'm doing.
I just don't understand
why people relegate
into losing mentality and
just thinking they can't.
You can't because you want
to be on the bowling team
or softball, play video
games, that's why you can't.
There's plenty of time, get shit done.
Now you watch a little Gary
V, you get a little motivated
you decide to actually
work on Friday night.
But then you wake up Saturday right?
And you're feeling good,
- Mm-hmm.
- [Gary] And then you grab your phone
and you go on Instagram
and the first thing you see
is your boys or the people that
you look up to in the club,
pretty girls, jewelry,
- Right, money flashing.
- And money and all of a sudden
you're FOMO'd the fuck out.
You know motivation's exciting
but the practicality of an execution
is even more importantly,
and so I sit here today
and I make this video.
If I can get one person to
be like, fuck he's right,
like what the hell am I doing here?
Friday can not be the best day of the week
because if it is you've already lost,
and you need to figure
out how to fix that.
And whether that's side hustle
from 7:00 p.m. to midnight,
and whether that's networking
from 7:00 to 9:00 p.m.
with other job opportunities,
and whether that's taking
a financial step backwards
to take a job that you love
that you can grow up into.
Please recognize the
world we're living in.
This is not your grandpappy's life.
We have the internet,
you can make shit happen.
You can build businesses or side hustles.
Your grandparents couldn't
do the things you can do.
Your grandparents didn't
have the internet,
your grandparents couldn't
be practical nine to five
then come home, do their
family thing and then
from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the
morning do something online
that could have been the thing
that switched them
outta their nine to five
and created their freedom.
They didn't have that option.
We do, everybody in this room does.
We live in a 24 seven world.
And people get mad at me again
because, Gary, fucking I
look forward to the weekends.
I love my family, it's not all about money
you're such an asshole, its family.
I'm like, no, no, no,
you're not listening.
I'm talking about if you genuinely dislike
what you do so much
that you beg for Friday.
And the only way you're
gonna work 15 hours a day
and pay that sacrifice to
be away from your loved ones
and travel and hustle is
if you're doing something
around a subject matter that you live
and breathe and die for.
Please take this permission,
this energy to start
trying and don't give up.
Be patient.
Please do not waste the next
five, 10, 15, 20, 30 years of your life
and allocate 30, 40, 50,
60 percent of your time
to something that you cheer
to end each and every week.